definitivamente en la lucha contra el
cambio climático no solamente puede
partir de los gobiernos sino que se hace
necesario las estrategias y alianzas con
el sector privado indispensable para
poder trabajar juntos en soluciones a
estos problemas sin lugar a dudas que la
sociedad civil también juega un rol
importante en este aspecto y de tal
manera que en república dominicana que
sera
sede de la semana del cambio climático
ahora en mayo y también en agosto
esperamos que sea presencial y
semipresencial pues vamos a estar
trabajando de cara a fortalecer la
posición como país y como continente
hacia la cumbre del cambio climático